i feel like i'm running around like a  chicken with his head cut off whenever  i'm like oh a little bit of time then i  squish four projects into it that don't  fit and then i'm like i have no time how  have you structured your life you have a  morning routine morning routine starts  the night before i get as much sleep as  my body will  take eat right exercise meditate always  have a list of the important things that  i should be working i also have a vision  for the company and my life what i'm  trying to accomplish monday through  friday if i'm awake i'm either working  or working out i don't have sex during  the week  on the weekends primary objective is my  marriage